[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hello, everybody
Thank you so much for coming.
This is going to be "Where
Should I Run My Code."
Let's go.
Got a lot to cover.
So quick question-- how many
people here kind of write code
on a semi-regular basis?
OK, lots of the
room, maybe 60%, 70%.
How many people here
keep code running,
like keep servers running,
keep infrastructure running,
like all the pieces?
So kind of 40%, 50% here.
And how many people
are coordinators
of some kind, managers, like
PGMs, like all these things?
And another kind of 20%, 30%.
So everybody does a
lot of different things
at the same time.
Awesome.
OK, so I think this will
be useful for all of us.
And it's like, where
should I run my code?
And sorry-- it depends.
And hopefully, through
the next about 40 minutes,
we'll talk through a whole bunch
of the trade offs and options.
So first, this is
Google Cloud Next.
So we have blue hexagons.
If you happen to know what
these are already, you're good.
You're all set.
The kind of proper names for
the various pieces here--
and I kind of put them
in this order on purpose.
There's kind of a stack,
an abstraction stack.
And you get more abstract and
you get more concrete kind
of down at the bottom.
So we've got, basically,
Compute Engine or VMs,
hosted Kubernetes clusters
of running collections
of containers, App Engine, which
is a platform as a service,
and Cloud Functions, which
is functions as a service.
So you input-output.
And the takeaway,
if you want to get
to lots of talks
at the same time,
is I'm going to make the case
that the majority of the time,
if your work looks
like these things,
like you might really strongly
consider starting here
and you may branch
out from there.
And we'll talk
about why we think.
But basically, if
you've already got
code that exists and is
running well, put it in a VM.
Make it work well.
If you are primarily
working in containers,
hosted Kubernetes or
Kubernetes somewhere
is going to be a
really great choice.
If you're primarily
working with code
that talks to the
internet and maybe
needs to scale up and down
very quickly over the web,
App Engine is a great choice.
And if you're primarily
reacting to things happening,
events happening, and
you need to do something,
functions are a really
good choice there.
So that's the quickie version.
And deep breath-- no worries.
I'll try to convince
you of that by the end.
We can move around between
these abstractions.
So we're going to
talk kind of bottom
up or, go through all
those, and then I'm
going to actually
answer the question
where should I write
my code, and then
give you some ideas of
where to go from here.
So Compute Engine-- these
are virtual machines.
They are logically
computers, the same kinds
you'd plug-in and
use other places,
but running in Google Cloud.
And you can have really quite
large computers these days.
You know, lots of CPUs,
lots of memory, lots of disk
attached, lots of graphics
processing your GPUs
and sensor processing units
if you're doing machine
learning for this stuff.
And one of the things that's
really interesting, I think,
about our VMs is that
all of these pieces
are individually configurable.
So if you have a workload
that is very memory intensive
but doesn't do much
compute, or the opposite,
or needs a huge amount
of storage space,
you can actually make a
machine that's that size
and save you a bunch of
money, versus just making
a huge, large computer.
So that's useful.
They start quickly for virtual
machines, like around tens
of seconds.
So 10, 20 seconds per machine.
And these are computers.
They're running a
whole operating system.
So we have images built for
various Linux operating systems
and then also Windows
operating systems.
And you can create
your own image
if you'd like to run something
very specific, perhaps
a company image or
things like that.
Diving into disk
just little bit,
because I think it's
an interesting example,
and they're true
throughout our compute.
But disk kind of
really makes it shine.
Our default disks are all
network attached storage.
So they're are
collections of pieces
of disk, parts of
thousands of physical disks
across a whole data center.
And so when you make
one larger, your disk
just gets faster and
faster and faster
as you use more and
more of the data center.
And it allows you to take
snapshots live, copy those
to another machine, make a
new computer out of them,
maybe in another part
of the world, easy
backups, that sort of thing.
So as you're
thinking about these,
like virtual machines
feel like computers,
but every aspect of it
is at data center scale.
So your disks, your
networking, your load balancer,
all this stuff.
So I guess try to
keep an open mind
as you're evaluating the
different pieces, because you
can make exactly the
size computer you want,
make it as fast as you need,
and change these on the fly,
including changing the
disk size without rebooting
the machine, which is handy
if anybody's ever run out
of disk before, which I've done.
And kind of more than
just virtual machines.
So if you make a machine
that you really like and you
want to have sibling machines
that do exactly the same work,
you can basically kind
of take that image
and make a managed
instance group
and say, OK, I'd like to
have five of those now.
Now I'd like 10,
back down to three.
And you can just have Compute
Engine just scale up and down.
And you can even do that
automatically based on load.
And just a moment to talk
about our load balancer--
if you want to dig
into the details,
there's a paper on
it called Maglev.
The internal name
is called Maglev.
And our load
balancers that you're
using, from Compute
Engine and all the rest
the products I'm going
to talk about today,
are actually the data
center scale load balancers
that we use to run
all of Google off of.
So when you're making a
configuration change here,
it's the same load
balancing infrastructure,
which means it scales up
and down incredibly quickly.
You can make a new load
balancer, and within about
a minute, hit it with a million
requests per second of traffic
and then drop down to
nothing, and it works.
So with you as a developer,
as a project manager,
as a team, when you're
using virtual machines
you're thinking
about your software,
the shape of the computer,
the operating system, what
the networking connections are.
It's very similar to working
with on premise hardware,
in a way.
But just be careful,
because it's all software.
But you're responsible for
all those same concerns.
So this is a really good
fit for lift and shift kind
of scenarios, where you
have existing software,
you want to bring it over.
A non-obvious one,
if you just want
to run one containerized process
on a computer of arbitrary
size, that's really easy
to do with Compute Engine.
You can point it at an image
and boot it up and have it go.
If you have a need for a really
particular version of a Linux
kernel or if you have
very specific licensing
requirements, this
can be the good,
or perhaps, only fit to do this.
It's great for running
databases and the like.
And you can do nearly all
of the network protocols.
UDP broadcast we don't do, but--
On the constraint side, it
takes about 10 to 20 seconds
to start up one machine.
You can start up thousands
in around a minute.
That's a pretty fast
response, but some loads
need faster response time.
So that might be a constraint.
And it's completely up to you
to manage the whole software
stack, which is important
to recognize, you know,
how you update your
software, and the like.
So what does this feel like?
I've been talking
for too long already.
Let's go.
OK, so this is the web interface
for Google Cloud Platform.
You've probably seen
demos and the like before.
But there's one thing that
is critical to understanding
this interface, and it's this
button, hamburger button.
All of the real
functionality is in there
to switch between
different parts of it.
So click on the hamburger
button, go find the thing.
So we will take a
look at Compute Engine
and come over here and
create an instance.
So we can give it a
name like "awesome."
We're going to make
it on the West Coast
because we are on the West
Coast right now, if I can read.
I guess we should do
it in Los Angeles, huh?
And we can basically choose a
whole bunch of pre-configured
machine sizes, including up to--
oh, in that region we don't
have all the biggest ones.
But this is where we
get to the customization
that we were talking about.
So if you want to have a
machine that is exactly
20 cores and not that much
memory or more memory,
you can kind of like,
move these sliders around
and create exactly the
shape machine you'd like.
So different regions have
different base chipsets
available, and the CPU family.
So if you are doing rendering
or other processes that
need very specific CPU
instructions, you can say,
I need to have this generation
or newer of CPUs, and the like.
And those do vary a bit by zone.
And we can, in here, choose
what kind of disk it's on.
Any of the kind of
pre-built things,
various linuxes,
different versions
of Windows Server and
the like, or your own,
and all kinds of
other fun stuff.
But I'm going to go ahead and--
oh, right before I hit Create.
Down here at the
bottom-- so when
you're learning
something new, you
want to be exploring, right?
So the web UI is
really good for that.
Once you figure
out what you want,
if you do it through
there, you can actually
click down here and get either
the exact kind of JSON payload
to pass to our API, or the
command line that would
create exactly the same image.
So you can then run this from
G Cloud and get the same thing.
So if I hit the Create button--
and we'll start a
mental timer going of,
you know, right
now we've actually
allocated the resources
to run this machine
and are actually kind of copying
this image out and booting
the machine up and waiting to be
able to actually run your code.
So once it goes green
on that check box,
it's handed off to
a startup script
that you can define to run
whatever your software is
on the computer.
And this is my favorite button.
Since I'm logged in to
Google Cloud with Olaf,
it knows who I am.
So it's actually pushing an
SSH key to this new instance,
and then it's going to connect
to me via the web over,
you know, to SSH
into the machine
and actually do work on it.
So we can take a look and we
can have some scrolling text.
Oh, I have to do that as pseudo.
It's real.
I got an error message.
And so we have
scrolling text proving
that it's a real computer.
Oh, bounce.
So that's a quick taste
of Compute Engine.
There's a whole lot there.
Please take a look.
So why might you
choose Compute Engine?
It is very consistent.
If you do your testing on
10 VMs in a given zone,
and later you want to use those
same 10 VMs somewhere else,
you should get very similar,
almost the identical behavior,
wherever you run them,
whatever you run them.
So it should be very consistent.
These custom sizes,
live disk resize.
In other talks they
probably talked in detail,
but basically, if you
use the same shape
instance for a long
time they get cheaper
over the course of a month.
So sustained use
discounts automatically
if you leave that going.
If you have batch
jobs, we have something
called preemptible VMs.
So they're VMs
that are guaranteed
not to live more than 24 hours,
might shut off at any time.
But they're dramatically
less expensive to run.
And behind the
scenes, if we were
planning to do any work
on the host machines,
we actually move the
VMs to another computer
without dropping
network connections,
usually within
milliseconds to do that.
And it's naturally a good fit
for almost all the software
that's out there currently.
It's running on computers
with networks between them
and that sort of thing.
And by the way, we do
run services on top of GC
ourselves.
So Kubernetes Engine, our Cloud
SQL instances, and other things
are actually running on
top of Compute Engine.
So a lot of what we're
going to talk about later
inherits all of these qualities
that we just talked about.
So head to the docs--
all sorts of information
about Compute Engine there.
And there are quite
a lot of talks,
but here's a few selected
talks to check out
for more details
about Compute Engine.
So photo time, and done.
OK, so Kubernetes Engine,
as you might guess,
is Kubernetes hosted
on Google Cloud.
So anybody heard of containers?
Thank you for the laugh.
So how many people have
heard of Kubernetes, though?
I'd like to get a sense.
So like, kind of heard the word.
How many people are using
Kubernetes in some fashion,
anywhere?
OK, quite a lot, maybe 10%, 20%.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
So the quick version of kind
of why containers, in my mind.
Have you ever
heard somebody say,
well, it works on my machine.
I mean, containers basically
solve that problem.
It actually works
in all the places,
because it has the exact same
binary and the same file system
that you use to test
and to validate,
and you bring that to
production and bring it
to the other machines.
So in a short, that's my
personal feeling there.
Kubernetes comes into play when
you have lots of containers.
And you want to think
about multiple computers
and large numbers of
containers as one system,
and reason about it in that way.
So it is inspired by systems
built previously at Google,
and built in the open, like
released in public, you know,
at a point one release, and got
dramatically better because we
worked with real use cases
with real users, lots
of contributions from a
lot of different companies,
a lot of individuals.
Just crossed over
20,000 contributors.
The Cloud Native Compute
Foundation owns all the IP.
It is 100 percent open
source, and at this point,
runs pretty much everywhere.
So it's worth looking
into, in my opinion.
But conceptually,
you're thinking
more about applications
than computers,
so logical infrastructure.
And the short
version is, you know,
when you get together
with a colleague
and you're trying to
explain how something works,
you immediately start drawing
things on the white board--
Kubernetes is not far from
writing config files that look
like those lines and boxes.
I mean, it's in YAML and
text, so it's more fiddly.
But conceptually, you're
connecting the application
to the database to the backend
service that like, runs.
And you're actually
defining those connections
in config and telling
Kubernetes to be
responsible for
making that continue
to work, which is awesome.
And then Kubernetes Engine
is hosted Kubernetes.
So there is some effort involved
in kind of running a cluster
and keeping it up to--
working to getting one
started for the first time
to like, evaluate whether you
even care about Kubernetes.
So if you're doing
an evaluation,
it really makes a lot
of sense, in my opinion,
to go straight to
Kubernetes Engine.
You can get one running
in about five minutes
and see if it works for you
in the projects you have,
and go from there.
And basically, it keeps the
individual computer nodes up
to date.
It updates Kubernetes
itself, helps you
with auto scaling and things
like that, and a whole bunch
more now.
So this is a really
good fit if you
are running multiple
environments of any kind
and you need to kind
of insulate yourself
from the differences
between them.
And that can be multiple clouds,
it can be in your own machines
with a cloud, it can be
different dev test prod
environments that you
want to behave the same
but are actually
isolated from each other,
those kinds of things.
It does need, in my
opinion here, again,
good team communication.
Because we're actually mixing
some of the responsibilities
that have been traditionally
kind of separated.
You know, security
folks, the people
who own the computers,
the people who
are responsible for
the software running
on them, all of those pieces.
They need to have
good communication.
You're probably much better
off if you have source control
with config and your
application data,
you know, the apps
that you write,
and go through some sort of
build process so that everyone
who makes changes, they go
through the same process
and end up in a test
environment later production.
It kind of implies it
works much better that way.
One big constraint is
Kubernetes only runs containers.
So you do need to get your
software kind of wrapped up
in a container.
There can be some fiddly
bits around licensing.
Some software is
licensed per physical CPU
that it ever runs on.
So you need to pay
extra attention
to not run it in too many
computers, things like that.
And you know, maybe some
architectural details
if you've got an app that
has really particular needs
about how the pieces of it
communicate to each other.
Might not be a perfect
fit in that case.
What this looks
like in practice--
over here on Kubernetes
Engine, I actually
have, in cooking show style,
I have a cluster already
deployed, and I have set up
a service that is listening
to, right now, nothing.
So you click on it and
you get nothing back.
And if we go in here,
this is a kind of Google--
you know, the Kubernetes
Engine UI for managing
things in a cluster.
You can also do this all
from the command line,
and same story--
you can get kind of
the raw config file
for what we do in the
UI, so that you can
do that programmatically later.
And I'm going to create
a new set of pods, which
are a collection
of processes that
have their own kind
of-- they're doing work.
And I'm going to like,
use an image that's
already built called nginx.
And this is a web server that
is very, very popular, runs
very well.
So this will be just a default
deployment of a web server.
And I'm going to leave all
the other stuff default
and click Deploy here.
And basically, it's kind of
making some decisions for me,
like configuring an auto scaler
and kind of a default number.
We start with three copies
of this running somewhere
in our cluster, and then
depending upon CPU load,
we'll actually deploy more
or fewer pods over time.
And this adjusts pretty rapidly,
depending on how much usage
it's actually getting.
And so that can be based on
CPU or a lot of other things
to actually scale the pods up
and down inside of the cluster
that is already running.
And then separately, cluster
size can also be scaled.
So now, if we come
back to services,
click on this same
thing, we have,
ta-da, a brand new nginx thing.
Isn't that amazing?
But that's a really
quick kind of intro
that I think the main
takeaway there is,
once you have the
cluster up, you
tell Kubernetes what state
you want the world to be in,
and it's its job to
keep it that way.
So if one of these
processes dies,
Kubernetes will restart it.
If one of the computers
that one of the nodes
that Kubernetes cluster
is made up of goes away,
it will be restarted.
And basically, that lets us all
kind of sleep better at night,
is that is the main thing there.
So let's go back to the talk.
So you might choose Kubernetes.
Like I said before, it
kind of insulates you
from changes of
different environments.
It gives you kind of a higher
level of abstraction to reason
about, but still lets you
do almost all the things
you want to do in software.
One of the main
reasons Google invested
in this kind of technology
is to save money, actually.
So it enables you to
pack a lot more software
together on the same computers,
without messing each other up.
Because you have the
isolation from containers,
you can specify how much CPU
and memory you want each of them
to use, and they
scale up and down
within the set of machines.
So instead of having computers
kind of sitting aside in case
you get traffic to
them, you can actually
have multiple different
applications running
in the same space and
scale up and down as needed
and save a bunch of
money, especially
if you're running in cloud,
where you can actually
change the number
of nodes that you're
paying for at the same time.
And the distraction level, the
white boarding kind of level,
is a real sweet spot for
a lot of communication
and for a lot of reasoning
about your systems.
You might choose
Kubernetes Engine,
like I said, because
it's managed,
lets you focus on it
a bit more, very quick
start, automatic
updates, good stuff.
So again, check
out the docs first
and there are
multiple talks here.
This is actually only
a small fraction.
I think we have
something like 20
or 30 Kubernetes related
talks at the event.
And some of the things from
yesterday are already online.
So check those out and send
them to friends, colleagues,
and the like.
And moving on.
So App Engine-- this is the
transition from infrastructure
into kind of
developer-focused code.
So how long can I avoid
saying serverless?
Let's see.
Oh, not very long.
That actually wasn't
super intentional.
So App Engine primarily
is made and was
made to help your
developers, which
would be you, focus on code
and just push that up and let
us handle the rest.
And its kind of sweet spot is
things that scale up and down
really rapidly.
It's perfectly
fine running things
with consistent workloads, but
it adapts very, very quickly
based on actual activity.
Each of the process is actually
run inside of a container,
and so they spin up on our
infrastructure very quickly.
It's actually been
around quite a while.
It started in 2008.
At that time, and up
until fairly recently,
there have been quite
a few constraints
around the kind of code you
could run on App Engine.
Had to be certain run times.
Only allowed certain libraries
within those languages
to be used.
Last year, we announced
the flexible environment,
which is basically
App Engine managed
VMs, kind of running containers
in those VMs, which enables you
to run a wide
variety of languages,
completely custom Docker
images and the like.
And just recently, like
yesterday, I think,
we announced several new second
generation run times that
are App Engine standard style.
But they are the same
language environment
that you would get just
by downloading Python
or downloading Node.js, PHP.
We're starting
with three of them.
This is in the
"coming very soon,"
like next week or
so kind of frame.
And why this kind
of all of a sudden?
The old run times we used
to take a lot of effort
to secure them, make special
versions and the like.
And the key
difference is gVisor.
And this is a recently
open source project
that allows you to run untrusted
code safely, without a VM
abstraction in between.
So it's basically
a syscall proxy
for applications on Linux,
and let's kind of safe calls
through to the kernel
and blocks other calls.
And it's running in
user land, so it's
very robust in terms
of being independent
from attacks in the kernel.
So gVisor and pieces around
this make us confident
that we can run,
essentially, arbitrary
code safely across our fleet.
And it's allowing us to
move much, much faster
in updating App
Engine, which leads us
to a slightly more complicated
space to reason about.
So hopefully, this
is a useful kind
of breakdown of these three
different environments
and some of the
trade offs there.
So this talk is a choose
with a choose inside of it.
But basically, the--
I don't know.
[? Maybe they ?] don't
make sense on its own.
But the two to the
left, the standard ones,
are sandboxed
individual processes
running on [? serverless ?]
set of machines.
Flexible is actually
managing virtual machines
in your project.
And you can write
an arbitrary code,
you can resize those to whatever
size machine you would like,
that sort of thing.
The 2nd gen and
Flexible are using--
you basically use Google
Cloud APIs directly.
The original standard
run times, many of them
existed before the
rest of Cloud existed.
And so they kind of
were incorporating
things that are now part of
Cloud normally, a blob store.
We just recently
announced a scheduler,
which is basically our crawl in
service, and things like that.
So all of those are available
to all of our execution
of environments now.
So the new pieces
use those directly.
And the big deal for
developers, in many ways,
is that you can run any Python
module, any kind of no JS
extension.
And just write the
code the same way
you'd write it in
other environments
and it should just run.
So when you're
working in App Engine,
you are thinking about
the code you're writing,
HTTP requests and responses,
and versions, which
I'll demo here in a second.
But basically, you have
a version of your code
and then you can have
a whole other version
of the application deployed
at the same time, which
is kind of cool.
So let's take a look at that.
Oh, before we do, the
constraints thing.
So it is a really
good fit for anything
that is kind of HTTP
request and response based.
Stateless applications are
particularly easy to scale.
And I talked to one earlier--
if you have applications
that scale very rapidly, perhaps
from almost zero to millions
of requests per minute or per
second and then back down,
that's a really good fit
for that sort of thing.
And actually, refer back
to this for constraints.
So demo-- so let's
take a look at this.
So the App Engine dashboard
looks a bit like this.
And I have one app deployed.
And if we take a look at
it, all it does is return
an image of lemons.
This is an amazing application.
Thank you for laughing.
However, I have
gotten some feedback
that not everyone
likes lemons, even
though I love the sour lemon.
So we have actually created
some different versions
of the application.
And they're all
deployed simultaneously.
And we can actually kind of poke
at the serving URLs for them
directly.
So this is actually a
cherry dot, this site.
And so you can actually test
and look at and have people
evaluate, have scripts run
against different versions
of the application
at the same time,
while the main one is
serving a previous version.
So that's pretty cool.
And then when you decide--
actually, let's check here.
So we have options.
So lemon's the current state.
How many people like cherries?
Some cherries, or not.
How about apples?
More apples than cherries.
And durian?
Oh, we have some durian lovers.
Just because, we're
going to go with durian.
So what we can do
is actually say
we're going to ignore
popular opinion,
and I'm going to actually
move the site over
to being 100% durian.
And then when we come back to
our main site and new users
on the next request,
they're going
to get this version of the site.
So that's kind of a
straight cut over.
But the really cool
thing is that we can then
cut back just as easily.
So I can come here and
say, you know, actually,
let's go confusingly 100% lemon.
Go back, maybe I will
leave this open next time.
And then when we refresh, we
get all lemons from there on.
Or if you want to do a
percentage of your traffic,
you want to test out your new
features without committing
to all of your users seeing
it, you can use the same tool
and basically say, actually,
we want to go just, say, 30%
apples.
Hit Save there.
And then as we refresh this,
Refresh, Refresh, Refresh,
Refresh--
oh, you know what?
I need to use the
Shift, because caching.
Maybe.
Let's try closing it
all the way, click.
See how smart I am
about web stuff?
AUDIENCE: Do you
have to save it?
SPEAKER 1: Did I not save?
No, we got it saved.
Probably.
Sorry.
That's what you get for
extending your demo on the fly.
Some of the users are going
to get lemons, some of them
are going to get cherries.
Thank you.
So App Engine left
developers focused on code.
We handled the rest.
Great for web focused workloads,
great for variable load.
We're serving well over
100 billion requests a day
on App Engine for
many, many users.
So please check out the docs
there and various talks.
And we'll do the
moment for photos.
And done.
Cloud Functions-- OK.
So this is functions
of the service.
And functions, in
the abstract sense,
are a thing that
you give some input
and then it gives some output
or has a side effect, right?
And so this is kind
of in some ways kind
of the purest form of code.
You just focus on this
specific thing you want to do.
It's got some inputs,
it does something,
and you get some
output, probably.
It was a little
not obvious to me,
but one way to reason about
this is it's functions
that get invoked from something
happening in the world.
So an event happens.
So we can do events
from a lot of places,
including our Pub/Sub tools
from cloud storage changes,
from HTTP requests that
come in from somewhere
if you're using Firebase from
various hooks in Firebase.
And it is serverless.
The definition I'm
using of serverless
is anything that--
and App Engine
fits this as well,
actually-- but anything
that you're doing
work for money.
So like, you're paying
for a unit of work,
not just reserving a thing
for a certain amount of time.
So you pay for some amount
of work that happens.
So that's roughly
the definition there.
It has been no JS and JavaScript
kind of for the last year plus.
We just announced that very,
very soon, Python 3.7 support
will be added, and
you can see continued
release of new
environments soon upcoming,
including something that
is worth checking out,
will be on the blog over
time, but the ability to run
containers on top
of Cloud Functions,
so you can kind of wrap
up whatever code you have
and have that work.
So that's going to be on
a kind of [? whitelist ?]
sign up early access program.
So take a look at
that in the future.
As the developer,
you're thinking
about events and the function
definition and kind of what
comes in and out
of the function.
And that's basically it.
Oops.
Shall we edit slides on the fly?
Look at that-- updated.
So it is a really good fit for
anything that's event driven.
When you really
don't want to think
about the runtime
environment, you
want things to
happen automatically.
Something that may be
a little not obvious
is a lot of data transformation
flows really look like this.
You just kind of feed
them some changes
and it updates other systems
based on those changes.
So you kind of have the ETL
workloads that a lot of people
use.
And in my mind, it's basically
kind of the glue for the Cloud.
You know, you want to
connect this API to that API,
and then do this other
thing as a side effect.
It's a really good fit for that.
One of the constraints
is you pretty much
have to interact via events.
Can be a HTTP call via events.
Your code is in this
function level granularity.
So as you get more
functions, you
have to reason about them as
the system gets more complicated
and figure out how you're going
to do logging and monitoring
and things like that.
And the quick, quick
demo there is missing.
There we go.
So I have cleverly deployed
a function already.
It is a very amazing
function that
basically takes this
request in, looks
in the body of the request
for something called message,
and then returns that.
So inside of Functions
here, so you can actually
kind of update them from here.
This is the URL if you're going
to create an event over HTTP.
If I click on that
right now, I'm
not actually sending any data.
So I get the no message
defined response.
And if I want to
send some data--
copy this example here--
there's a little kind
of in browser testing
that you can do and basically
say, hello, lovely Next folks.
And hit Test, and we get a
hello world back and forth.
So I mean, really,
there is no developer--
like dev environment,
it's straight JavaScript
if you want to do it.
You can also do it
from the command
line using regular
tools, but you
can do it all through the web.
Very straight forward, and
then connect these together.
And there we go.
So you don't even have
to think about servers.
That's where the
serverless comes from.
Pay only for what you use.
A very straightforward
developer experience.
And docs and talks and
photos, 3, 2, 1, gone.
OK, so where should
I run my code?
Let's get to the actual talk.
It still depends.
But on what?
OK, so maybe in listening
to this and the things
I talked about, you
already thought,
OK, I need to check this out,
or I need to look at that.
So awesome.
And it depends on
several other things
that I wanted to go into
a little more detail on.
This kind of, what
abstraction level
do you want or need to
be working at, what kind
of technical requirements you
have for the language you're
using, the way you talk
to it over the network,
whether it has
licensing or kernel
limitations, things like that.
And then your team, your
organization, your colleagues.
Like what skills
and interests do
you bring to writing software?
So in terms of what
you think about,
this is kind of a
summary of the things
I talked about across
the different sections.
So at each level of
abstraction, the way
you think about the code is
actually quite different.
So you may decide
that, actually, we
want to spend most of our
time focusing on code.
Or we want to spend most
of our time focusing
on how the pieces
connect to each other,
and that sort of thing.
So that might be
a reason you use
to start in a certain place.
There are certain
technical requirements
that will kind of pull you
down the stack, if you will.
So if you need a very
specific kernel version,
you're going to go all
the way to Compute Engine.
If you need, you know,
if you want your code
to run pretty much
the same across really
diverse environments,
you're going to get
pulled at least to
Kubernetes, maybe
virtual machines,
that sort of thing.
When you need, you know, to run
very specific languages, that
might get you an App Engine.
And there's several
other constraints
as you get into like, research
and docs, that might kind of
push you one way or the other.
And in some ways, this is
kind of the serverless break,
if you will.
Like if your team is
primarily developers and want
to focus on the code
and that sort of thing,
you're probably going to be in
the App Engine and the Cloud
Functions kind of space.
If you have good
team integration,
you've got folks
who are engaging
in how the systems work
together, and like,
all in on containers, and
there's knobs and parts
that you really need
to control or want
to control for your
business needs,
Kubernetes is going
to be a great fit.
And if coming over
from existing things
or, you know, you
want to kind of work
your way into Cloud step
by step, very deliberately.
Starting with VMs is a
really good place to go.
So Compute Engine.
If you're running in lots
of different environments,
this might also do things.
So this slide's a
little funky, but there
are virtual machines in kind
of almost every environment.
Like you probably have
them at your own offices,
maybe on your laptop.
All the Cloud
providers have them.
So if your stuff runs
in virtual machines,
you can run it in
lots of places.
Kubernetes essentially
runs everywhere right now
and gives you a lot of
insulation from the things
that do change in the
different environments.
So it's a really
good choice for that.
The work that's ongoing in the
community around Envoy, Istio,
Knative and others,
really are beginning
to make a really good start
at the kind of platform
as a service, more like
focusing on the apps and code,
and then inheriting
that insulation
so that you can
run them anywhere,
like that you get
from Kubernetes.
So that's worth thinking about.
And then if you've
got functions that
are kind of run in JavaScript
or other languages,
you can probably
move them very easily
between different
functions' environments.
So kind of things to think
about, like equivalency.
If you're already kind of
in one of the other places,
look at these pieces.
Or if you want to
make sure that you
are able to kind of run
in different scenarios,
think about these pieces.
So I mentioned
Knative here, right?
What is that?
It was in the
announcements yesterday,
but it's basically
an open source
project to kind of help
build additional higher
level primitives.
Kubernetes is very much kind
of infrastructure, high level
infrastructure, but
infrastructure project.
And the Knative,
Istio, envoy pieces
are kind of helping us
like, reason at the appli--
you know, specifically
at the kind of like,
developer focused
code app level,
like all the way up to
almost doing functions.
So please take a look at that.
Back to here.
And here's the crux
of the thesis here.
So why is this no worries?
I think the key thing is, if
you get code into containers,
you can run it in all the
different environments.
And real systems--
[INAUDIBLE] say
it-- most systems
end up running
multiple services,
multiple different
run times in the end.
They may have some piece of
third party code that only runs
in a particular environment.
Maybe it needs Windows and
it talks to other stuff,
and then you have
another part that's
in functions, because it makes
sense from the data processing
standpoint, that sort of thing.
So it's very common
to run multiples
in the same overall system.
And if you are doing
that, please take a look
at both Pub/Sub
and Cloud storage.
If you notice you look at
architectural diagrams,
or if you talk to the
Cloud solutions folks,
almost every system will use
Cloud storage and/or Pub/Sub.
Because we actually don't have
local file systems anymore,
or as we're kind of scaling
these things up and down,
you need to have
good coordination
between the machines.
You need places to put
data and get it back out.
So you use a lot of databases.
You'll use Cloud storage
and Pub/Sub a lot.
So take a look at those.
They are not the flashiest
bits, but they're everywhere
and super, super useful.
So if you do get your
code into containers,
you can then move
it relatively easily
between the different
abstraction levels.
In particular, for example,
if you write an app
that you deploy to
App Engine Flex,
as a side effect
of doing that, it's
actually created a
Docker image, built it,
and written that to a registry.
So you've got this image
that's sitting there.
And so you can take that
URL and point to Kubernetes
cluster out of it and say,
run that, and it will run.
You can take that same URL and
put it into the VM creation UI,
and run that same
image from there.
So kind of working
down the abstraction
works like quite smoothly.
Going up a level, you may need
to do a little manual work
in some places, but it
should be quite compatible,
so if you are
already in containers
that helps move up and down
between these abstractions,
if you decide you need to later.
So start with these.
This is the too long,
didn't read version.
Start with these.
And then as needed, you
can move as necessary.
So that's why I believe
no worries on that.
We seem to be winding down.
I will release folks, and I'll
be hanging out to the side
and then moving out into
the hallway pretty quickly.
Super happy to
hang out and talk.
Thank you all for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]